I love a roof gig. This goes horribly. I can just jump right off.
Hey. Hey. Hey, knock. 'em dead comedy.
All right. Just a heads up all the way up. No elevator.
It's not going to be pretty.
That's my agent.
Hey, look at that company. Share. Wow. Hey, new stuff. Don't judge me.
It's going to be rough, but thanks for coming. Fadi I'm going to go first,
but uh, you got a minute? Yeah, go, go and take a boom. Boom.
You seen him on comedy central. Please give a warm.
Welcome to Mark Norman.
Hey, thank you. Hey buddy. Uh,
I don't know if any of you guys have kids that sucks for you guys with the
schools being closed. It's actually good for me though.
Cause now I can drive by him again. Hold on,
wait for the MTA. God it never been handled by a train.
Um, I just don't understand what's going on as much. You know,
Corona's a lot like the stock market. I checked the numbers every day.
It keeps fluctuating and I don't know what's happening,
but I know I'm still losing money. Um,
a lot of couples here, that's exciting that guy's exhausted. All right,
this is good. I'm working on jokes and getting skin cancer.
I know this feels more like summer camp.
Doesn't it sip this booze and less pedophiles.
This is nice to be out and everything. I'm actually a quarantee with my abuser,
my brain. Thank you.
Woo. Woo. I can't be illegal.
Last show of the night folks up on a roof
in Manhattan.
I got to get that puppy down
on the fifth floor and then we can go up there and bomb.
Without further ado. Ladies and gentlemen, I'll bring him up to the stage.
Give it up for the one and all that Mark.
Thank you, sir. All right. Appreciate it. Here we are.
And the Epstein's fourth home. This is nice sexy place.
Hey John Wilkes booth seat over there.
Don't shoot me. Good crowd. I've been watching the NBA.
Uh, the stands are empty, so it's a weird, the NBA is weird with it.
The empty stands. No we should do just to fill those up,
let's take the racist statues and put them in the stands.
Black guys like that one. Scared to laugh now. Why he's.
It's a, it's a comedy is over for her honkies. You guys have fun.
The last girl was a bunch of queefs you guys are all right. Just like, Oh,
I can't believe you said that. I'm like, yeah, I'm a comedian. You retard.
All right. All right.
Well that's one of us. Um, cool.
All right. I don't like me.
So I'm glad you do went to a strip club in Texas, not too long ago.
They're still open where the woman has the mask on, but no underwear.
I treated one lip for another, you know? And, uh, it's crazy. Cause you know,
you got a lady's vagina in your face, but if you're like, Hey,
if you cough on me, I'll kill you. Thanks a lot. I'm Kevin,
you guys are great. Thank you, Laura show. You're going to love it.
Have a good night.